[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Wow.
That is tremendously nice.
Thank you very much.
Well, happy Thanksgiving.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright.
Well, I will share this
with you --
I suffer from OCD,
obsessive-compulsive disorder.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
"Suffer" --
that word is overused,
don't you think?
I think the term "suffer"
should be reserved
for people writhing in agony
on the ground.
[ Laughter ]
They're suffering, you know?
Am I allowed to run up to them
"You're preaching to the choir!"
[ Laughter ]
"I have to alphabetize
everything!"
[ Laughter ]
"Quit wriggling around.
I'm trying to count your ribs!
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
The alphabetizing thing is not
true -- at least, in my case
People think
I'm weirder than I am,
and it's hard for me, you know
[ Laughter ]
Like, they ask questions, like
"Brian with your OCD,
do you have to alphabetize
your books at home?"
And I'm, like, "Uh, no."
[ Laughter ]
"I organize my books by
when I got them chronologicall
on the top shelf."
[ Laughter ]
I don't have to alphabetiz
my books.
I'm not a kook.
[ Laughter ]
And the bottom shelf is fo
the books I finished reading
organized chronologically.
[ Laughter ]
I don't have to
alphabetize them. Mnh.
[ Laughter ]
And the middle shelf
is for the books
I'm in the process of reading.
Those are organized
chronologically.
[ Laughter ]
When I start reading a book,
I just move it from the
top shelf to the middle shelf,
and I know exactly what
you're wondering --
"Well, wouldn't reading
the title of the book coun
technically as being in th
process of reading the book?
Then how would you distinguish
between the top shelf
and the middle shelf?"
[ Laughter ]
Well, the way I do it --
I make myself read
all of page one
before I allow a shelf change.
[ Laughter ]
I don't count the introduction
or the forward
or the book jacket.
I do read all of that
word for word,
but then I make myself rea
all of page one,
all the way to the bottom...
unless it ends
in the middle of a sentence --
I make myself turn the page.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I finish the sentence
to complete the thought.
I turn the page back.
I write down what date that book
was started
and move that
to the middle shelf
furthest on the right.
I don't have to alphabetiz
my books.
I'm not out of my mind!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Applause continues ]
You know, when I first suspected
that I might have OCD,
I Googled it.
And there are
different symptoms,
and some I have,
and some I don't.
And the ones I have, some I have
more strongly than others.
So I decided to make
a color-coded graph.
[ Laughter ]
I wish I was making this up.
I listed the symptoms,
and I said,
"I'm going to rate
from zero to 10
how strongly
I feel I have each symptom
I'll total it up and divide it
by the number of symptoms.
[ Light laughter ]
"If I'm higher than five,
I'll seek
professional treatment."
[ Laughter ]
"If I'm under five, I'll
self-diagnose that I am A-okay."
[ Laughter ]
Number one --
"Are you the type of perso
who has to check the stove
over and over again
to make sure it's off?"
And I'm, like, "Uh, zero.
That's 'Looney Tunes' land."
[ Laughter ]
Number two --
"Are you the type of perso
who has to wash your hands
repeatedly?"
And I had this nagging feeling
that I forgot to answer
that first question.
[ Laughter ]
So, I looked up.
Yeah, I did write zero.
Okay, hand washing?
[ Laughter ]
Six.
I'm, like,
"That ain't even right."
I scribbled that out.
I got some ink on my hands
I went to go wash my hands
[ Laughter ]
While I'm washing my hands
I'm like,
"Why did they mention stove?
So, I checked the stove.
[ Laughter ]
It was on.
I'm like, "I'm never going t
make that mistake again,"
and I came back, and
I changed hand washing to two.
[ Laughter ]
I did the whole test
and averaged 5.0.
So I'm like,
"I still don't know."
[ Laughter ]
So, I decided
to buy a book about it.
I got to get to the bottom of it
somehow, right?
[ Light laughter ]
I go into the bookstore.
I ask the clerk,
"Can you tell me where
the self-help section is?"
And she said, "Why don't you try
to find that yourself?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience groans ]
Well,
I finally found the section.
It was so disorganized,
I spent the next three hours
rearranging all their books,
rather than finding out
whether or not I have OCD.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much.
♪♪♪♪
Thank you.
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
Come here!